countries are shutting their borders to
foreign travelers in an attempt to keep
out the new omicron coronavirus variant
israel and japan have imposed total
travel bans despite world health
organization advice to keep frontiers
open scientists are saying it could take
weeks to fully understand the variant's
risk but many governments aren't waiting
they're bringing back curfews masked
mandates and new restrictions
5 pm in the netherlands a curfew for
bars and other venues kicks in a measure
taken to again curb the spread of the
coronavirus the netherlands has recorded
cases of the omicron variant all while
the world is still battling that delta
variant
for example here in germany with some
hospitals at capacity the german army is
transferring covet 19 patients around
the country to any hospital with a free
bed
now germany also has confirmed cases of
omicron to slow the variant the world is
going back to familiar measures like
curfews travel restrictions testing and
tracing but one important tool has not
been fully utilized
first and foremost highest priority is
vaccinate vaccinate vaccinate boost
boost boost as much as is possible
because this boosting or vaccination
raises the level of antibodies and
stimulates the memory cells
for covet viruses therefore this is the
police of the immune system that you are
reinforcing during that time
on the other side of the equator a
similar message south africa is calling
on its people to get vaccinated omicron
was first detected in the southern
countries of africa little to nothing is
known about the new variant how
infectious or dangerous it is
but since its discovery flights from
that part of the world have been
cancelled or delayed travel bans have
been imposed on several southern african
countries and tourists are struggling to
get home
it's all very strange everything was
fine when i flew in on november 11th
there was no hint of this variant
the last two weeks in cape town have
been great it's my ninth visit in three
years
they're trying to get the economy going
again everything's safe i have a lot of
german friends who also traveled here
everything went mad between nine and 11
a.m on friday morning
it's chaos incomprehensible yeah
those bands are unjustified say south
african leaders
we call upon these countries that have
imposed travel bans
on our country
and our other southern african sister
countries
to immediately and urgently reverse
their decisions
and lift the bans they have imposed
before any further damage is done on our
economies
and to the livelihoods of our people
manufacturers say they have plans in
place to adapt their vaccines if
necessary
but first they need to learn more about
the omicron variant
one of germany's leading virologists
says the omicron variant should be taken
seriously christian dawson said many
young people and those who recovered
from previous infections were among the
early cases
i'm quite concerned i'm surprised to see
so many mutations but then again these
mutations are the only things that are
observable so far we can't always know
right away what they will do in real
life
there have been media reports of the
disease leading to mild symptoms but i
don't think there's much substance to
that yet
we have only seen about a thousand cases
and it still has to be observed
we really have to be prepared for all
possibilities
what we can say however is that
infections have been mostly occurring in
young people often in those who have
already had the disease and then get it
for a second or third time
we really don't know what we're up
against yet
but what we can say with certainty is
it's better to be vaccinated
and it's even better to have had a
booster shot
okay for more on this let's bring in
he's the head of the division of medical
virology at stellenbosch university and
he joins me now from cape town thanks so
much for being with us uh one of
germany's leading virologists says we
just heard that he is worried about the
new variant as more omicron cases are
detected around the world how concerned
are you
absolutely the same situation i'm also
concerned mostly because of the
mutations that we are seeing it
basically has mutations that we know
from
other variants and that come with
negative effects on transmissibility
vaccine
evasion and so on and a few more and
what we don't know quite fully is how
they work together and what it actually
means in practice so my own lab and
other labs around the country are
isolating this new virus and run lab
experiments to determine how you know
how what it does and cell culture and
how well people who have been immunized
or who have recovered will be able to
neutralize the new virus that will give
very good indications and this will be
complemented by epidemiological studies
and they are also
they have started in fact to look at
cases and and as you said in in in the
report um so far most infections have
been in younger and otherwise healthy
people so we cannot really tell how bad
it is for those who we know are risk
groups so we are looking at this very
closely and i assume because of its
rapid spread here in the country that
over the next few weeks we will have
many more insights
so it's likely is it that this new
variant is more contagious than the
delta variant
it might well be but we have to keep in
mind that south africa is coming out of
a very quiet period as regards
infections and people were quite relaxed
about uh you know wearing masks and
avoiding gatherings so one always
wonders uh you know if if you are if
you're living dangerously of course your
risk of getting infected is increased um
so we again will have to see the full
details but what we know so far is is
you know it's giving reason to to be
concerned so i think we better be
prepared then then sorry afterwards
now what do we know about the efficacy
of existing vaccines and and how long
could it take um to adjust them so that
they can then tackle this new variant
i'm pretty confident that like with
previous variants and even if this new
variant omicron is is even worse than
the previous ones
the vaccines will still retain a very
good degree of protection against severe
disease and death so i fully concur with
professor drosten that being vaccinated
is the way to be and getting a booster
dose when you are eligible for a booster
dose is also the best thing to do
however it may of course reduce the
protective effect of the vaccines but it
is possible to twist to tweak these
vaccines in order to accommodate a new
variant and i hear that this is
happening already that's one of the
advantages of modern science where we
can have the sequences uh within a day
or two they are becoming available
worldwide and they are
then used by the manufacturers to to
look at new vaccines however it will be
several months if until the new vaccine
becomes available so you know don't
expect any quick solution and it's
certainly not a reason not to have your
uh basic immunization or your booster
dose right now
now since omicron was first reported
many countries have restricted travel
from southern africa south africa's
president says his country is being
unfairly punished would you say that
travel bans are effective and
appropriate now
well i'm worried about uh hearing so
many cases being detected
in fact this is why we sounded the alarm
bell early we wanted to give other
countries the chance to be on the
lookout for this new variant and that is
happening
um and yes i agree that it feels like
south africa is being punished for doing
what all countries should ideally be
doing i.e look at the evolution of the
virus in their population and give
alerts to other countries as early as
possible also we are doing that and we
didn't want to create panic we wanted to
give an advance warning to allow others
to manage this and and somehow of course
it feels it's not it's not good i think
one could definitely strengthen
travel safety by means other than just
blocking travel altogether for example
testing
on arrival is something that is not
being done and that could well be done
using the rapid antigen dates it would
only add another 15 or 20 min that's
very easy uh to to do why people are
waiting for their luggage of course it
needs to be organized but i think under
these circumstances one could actually
allow travel and do it very safely all
right dr wolfgang paiser virologist at
stellenbosch university in south africa
thank you so much for your time
well as the world reacts to the
emergence of omicron the world health
organizations holding a special meeting
to discuss a possible global agreement
on how to handle the next major health
crisis the meeting was opened by the
president of kazakhstan who said the
world was still failing to cooperate
all right apologies for the uh sound
problems there uh let's get more from
journalist and molecular biologist akai
kupva schmidt who joins us uh from here
in berlin welcome to dw um how
forgive me how concerned should we be
about omicron
well i mean clearly we should be
concerned i mean it is literally called
a variant of concern by the who as well
and
if we look at the the genome of this
virus it
has a lot of hallmarks of a virus that
might have learned to escape immunity a
little bit better that might have
learned to be more transmissible but for
now these are assumptions based on the
genome and based on the very limited
data we have from what is going on in
south africa um and so to find out how
concerned exactly we should be we really
have to to wait we have to do the
experiments we have to see real world
evidence and that's what's happening at
the moment so personally i am very
concerned i'm still hopeful that that
maybe it won't turn out quite as bad as
some of the assumptions that could be
made but
but we we're gonna have to wait for that
okay and what sort of time scale does
does that
look like how long before we know how
worried we should be
well it is
so these are different time scales for
different questions i think one of the
things we're going to be able to answer
fairly soon hopefully is how does this
particular variant stack up against the
immunity that we get from
vaccines or from from being infected and
recovering and and that's really
something that we can do in laboratory
experiments where we take the blood from
vaccinated people and we basically see
whether the antibodies in the blood
neutralize this new variant so that is
something that maybe in two weeks we're
going to have an answer maybe even a
little bit earlier than that there's
other questions in particular when we
look at um how severe the disease is
that is much much harder to parse i mean
you have to remember also that whatever
we see now in south africa um for the
moment it's it's
it's based on a small number of cases
and we really have to see
we have to follow these cases we have to
see how many of them are hospitalized
how severe the sickness is and then you
can't necessarily take what you see
there and apply it to a country like
germany where we have had much less
natural immunity for instance way less
infections overall in this pandemic so
that might take weeks to months actually
to really figure it out okay well so the
the who's now identified seven variants
of concern
have vaccines been tweaked as these
emerge or as or are today's vaccines
essentially the same as we were using a
year or so ago
no for now the vaccines are the same
ones that we've used a year ago and and
the reason for that is that if you look
at the variance of concerns so far most
of them have had an advantage in terms
of transmissibility they've especially
delta variant they've been much much
better at spreading but we haven't
really seen much immune escape the
variant that has had the most immune
escape so far has been the beta variant
which was also first detected in south
africa and that didn't really spread
around the world but we also know that
as immunity builds up in the population
around the world we are more likely to
see
variants that aren't necessarily more
transmissible or not only more
transmissible but also better able at
reinfecting people with immunity and so
it makes a lot of sense that we would be
seeing some of these variants coming up
now right and a quick word about
travel bans because the attitude of
experts seems to mirror their proximity
to affected regions those closer say
bans are an overreaction well those
farther away say well we're going on the
precautionary principle what's your take
i think there's quite a few experts who
uh you know live live in regions far
away from south africa and say that
these travel vans don't really make a
lot of sense i think the thing is
they
they can slow down the virus but that
also means that the travel ban has to
apply to a lot of regions and not just
south africa i mean we have seen this
this variant now crop up in a lot of
places so maybe what israel is doing
might actually work but all you're doing
is slowing down the the spread of this
variant and then the big question is
always what do you do with the time that
that gives you and since we're not
really doing what we should be doing for
instance in germany in our own country
to keep infections down you do have to
question you know how much a travel ban
like this is ever going to do if you're
not going to use the time all right good
talking to you thank you that's very
clear kai cooper schmidt molecular
biologist and uh journalist thank you
let's take a look at how omicron is
affecting things here in germany with
dw's chief political correspondent
melinda crane
welcome melinda so how is germany's
caretaker government reacting to omicron
well the fact is that many people see a
troubling standstill here in germany for
one reason because as you say we are in
a period of transition from the medical
government which is still in a
caretaker role to the new coalition that
will be led by the spd's olaf schultz he
is expected to be sworn in next week and
he is insisting that his government is
going to do everything necessary to
fight corona and omicron
those public statements uh are the one
side of it but the fact is is coalition
partners
are showing dissension and
indecisiveness a new crisis team that is
supposed to streamline decision making
by the new government could start
meeting in coming days even before the
coalition is in place but it's unclear
to what degree they will act and
meanwhile the old government is
essentially
at this point biding its time and an
additional reason for this vacuum on the
part of both the old and the new
government is the fact that they
essentially have delegated
responsibility to the country's highest
court in a sense it's going to issue a
ruling tomorrow on the legality of past
lockdown
measures and other restrictions uh but
again how the uh government old or new
will act on that is an open question and
meanwhile the head of the german
hospitals association says the country
is walking into a medical catastrophe
well i wanted to talk about that because
as you say the the the country's icu
capacity has already stretched and so
one wonders how omicron is likely to
affect healthcare resilience
well in fact
we are seeing intensive care units in
many hospitals across the country now at
breaking point the very disturbing word
triage is being used for what they're
having to do essentially decide which
patients to treat first and which
patients to try to send somewhere else
but apparently even hospital's capacity
to do the latter is uh is now
at stake so it is a very serious
situation indeed quick action is
required and as i said we're not seeing
that from the government at this point
okay thank you for that melinda melinda
crane dw's chief political correspondent
here are some of the other developments
in the pandemic around the world
japan has announced it will bar foreign
visitors starting tuesday as the country
tries to prevent the spread of the
omicron coronavirus variant swiss voters
have backed new legislation where people
who've been vaccinated recovered or
tested negative can attend public events
over 60 percent of voters backed the new
measures
and then the world health organization
will meet to discuss a pandemic treaty a
draft has already been agreed the treaty
would improve global preparedness for
future pandemics